Qué está pasando con el proceso
electoral en Guatemala porque hay
preocupaciones decir se puede hablar de
razones de peso para excluir a los
candidatos a quienes no se les permitió
la inscripción hasta este momento
Bueno un aspecto fundamental de un
proceso electoral
no haya discrecionalidad o inclusive
decisiones
y que las exclusiones que se puedan dar
sea sobre la base de razonamiento
jurídicos en el caso de Guatemala en el
marco de lo que presentó la ley
electoral y de partidos políticos cuando
cuando Esto no es así cuando se aplica
lo contrario cuando se me aplican
decisiones que tal parecería que tienen
una de un mercado sentido de orientación
política y cuando el órgano electoral en
el caso de Guatemala el tribunal supremo
electoral toma decisiones tal parecería
también acomodaticias pues el proceso en
sí mismo va tornándose se va empañando y
ese es el tono de las elecciones de este
año curso del año 2023 marcadas por eso
por punto una tonalidad cada vez más
gris un proceso disminuido que no arroja
Esperanza que no arroje ilusión a la
ciudadanía sino todo lo contrario y hoy
este día lunes que inicia el proceso
electoral tal parecería que es bastante
insípido y los donde los partidos en
lugar de llenar de en lugar de plantear
propuestas programas prioridades
elementos sustantivos te están desde ya
planteándose toda una presencia
mediáticas pero que no lo que generan es
dispersión en la ciudadanía puntualmente
qué es lo que ocurre en el caso de la
candidata indígena a la presidencia
Telma Cabrera
bueno el partido que el impulso es el
partido liberación de los pobres que
tuvo una participación importante en las
elecciones de 2019 que ocupó el cuarto
lugar y en esta ocasión postulan como
candidato a la vicepresidencia a el
procurador de los Derechos Humanos el
licenciado Jordan Rodas y tal parecería
que él se convierte se ha convertido en
una digamos una piedra en el zapato y el
el elemento central entonces de dejarlos
fuera de la del proceso obedece más bien
a razones de carácter político
especialmente orientados a la no
presencia de El señor Jordan Rodas quien
durante su paso derechos humanos
llevó a cabo una serie de acciones que
fueron considerados por diversos grupos
en el país como digamos como elementos
que hoy por hoy son se usa como anularlo
y la decisión entonces de dejarlo fuera
es Está marcado por eso por un nivel de
falta discrecionalidad usted estaba
mencionando algo de esto y se lo
pregunto puntualmente se puede hablar de
poca transparencia y falta criterio
jurídico como argumentan algunas
organizaciones a la hora de inscribir
aspirantes porque por ejemplo Hay
personas condenadas o señaladas por
delitos como corrupción y narcotráfico
Me parece que esos correctos a
valoraciones se han aplicado una serie
de decisiones que tal parecería como de
la de la puerta giratoria te dejan
entrar algunos y se obstaculizan la
participación de otros ese elemento
insisto se convierte en un elemento
fundamental en un proceso electoral y lo
empaña desde un inicio